Tony's with us in Modesto California hi
Tony how are you I'm doing great how are
you doing today better than I deserve
what's up awesome thanks for taking my
call I'm calling today to help you get
some help with my debt free journey my
wife and I have just started on this and
basically what we're trying to do is
we'll take a big chunk out of it by
renting out our place our home and we're
going to be moving into an RV living in
it full time and until get our all of
our debt taken care of come on Ellie do
you have uh we have a total of about
eighty nine thousand on what twenty-two
is in credit cards and the rest is
Fannie Mae how much do you owe on the RV
not nothing yet that's actually was was
one of my questions but you haven't
bought it
no we haven't even bought it yet oh okay
good okay and how much is your household
income uh seventy-nine a year good and
and how much is your house payment 602
dollars and what is the house worth two
hundred and forty five and what it what
do you owe on it
I'm a hundred and thirty-nine good okay
um well you're asking my opinion you're
not going to like it because you're kind
of emotionally deep down into this plan
I think it's a really bad plan because
you're going to buy an expensive piece
of machinery that goes down in value
very very rapidly
uncle RVs are horrendous on their
depreciation how much they lose in value
it's scary how much they lose now fast
they lose it so the for just starting
your get out of that plan aren't you
you're very very big in yet okay what I
would ask you to do if I were in the way
I answer questions on the show Tony is
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes okay right is if I woke up in your
shoes the first thing I would do is I
would give this six months to a year
really really hard tight budget living
with you're very modest house
I meant you have a great house it's very
low yeah yeah and let's just attack this
debt as hard as we can let's see how
we're doing there okay
do you hate your house no it's a
wonderful love it okay then if you
absolutely are stuck and you look up a
year from now and you paid off two
thousand dollars or five thousand
dollars instead of twenty or thirty
thousand like I think you should you
might have to sell the house and use
that money to clear the debt but I would
not rent it out and live in an RV okay
okay yeah I only came up with the idea
and helps to get this this dead taken
care of quickly well I appreciate that
and I appreciate your your willingness
and maybe your family's willingness to
sacrifice at that level Dave might live
in an RV I can tell you be by myself
though Sharon ain't going that works at
your house brother but I know how to
work in mine so should be going enjoy
yourself there so but anyway that I
think the house is an asset it's going
up in value I don't want renters moving
in your home and destroying it while
you're living in an RV I and I think
there's family aspects of this that are
involved as well now have you and your
wife gone through Financial Peace
University our nine week class yet I
don't even know what that is oh my
goodness okay we have a nine week class
on how to handle money that includes
budgeting and getting out of debt and
investing and all the stuff that you
need to know okay okay you go to class
once a week for nine weeks there are
classes taught in your area there it's
about a hundred bucks to go through it
and I want to give it to you as my gift
to you guys
Wow thanks Dave okay so I'm going to put
you on hold Kelly's going to pick up
it's called Financial Peace University
and she'll help you find a class or
teach you how to do that and we'll pay
for you guys to go through the two of
you you and your wife need to attend
both of you and then you guys work that
plan really hard really diligently for a
year and I think you're going to see
substantial progress to where you'll be
glad you didn't do the other plan
it ok 30 days hey man you hold on Kelly
I'll pick up and we'll help you do it
hey you guys Rachel crews here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey Channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you